can we get this question and the way
that out excuse me much more
straightforward can someone give me an
answer for Part A for say yet for
qualified to is it is there an extra bit
statement one and then for coin thank
you point by two yeah okay times 10 to
the five okay by the way how did you
know that that should have intended para
50 I only count two zeros their seasons
cuz reasons yeah man is just I keep very
good so when you think about this number
even though these guys are non zeros
right if you compare four and a half two
well that's a 450 1000 right how many
times does this decimal place you're
gonna have to hop down in order to give
you this number the answer is five times
okay so it's fine kind of this one we're
going to the other direction someone
give you hand I get it clue it starts
with a one half point yes so yeah I have
any okay so just think about it because
you have to be this rounding 43 CW
figures there's lots of information
there that it's irrelevant to you right
I personally like to round first and
then write the rest of it so you have a
look you think which are the three most
important numbers these guys here are
the biggest ones how do i noticed a it
103 rather than go up to 104
yes it's this guy that comes after right
which means I'm closer to Desmond oh how
about their sweated this negative one
come from what's that about yeah good
the disciplines is going to be other
direction positive I want a small number
not a big number in case that time notes
negative 1 earliest what okay when you
have a look at this next family of
questions right in some senses once you
sort of access the first one the rest
will become a lot easier but even so
there are some tricks I want you to
remember number one multiplication you
can multiply numbers in any order you
like right 2 times 3 times 5 is 30 right
so you could do 2 times 3 which is six 6
5 to 30 or if you wanted you could do
what else what other order you gonna do
you go to 2 times 5 which is Ted 3 tens
still 30 right so I've got here one two
three four numbers and i can multiply
them in any order I like so I'm gonna
rearrange them slightly and if you have
no working I'd love it like if you do
this on your calculator I love you to
follow with me and see how i'm working
the sound i'm going to put these two
numbers here this is these are both in
scientific notation and these are my
significant figures i'm going to put my
significant figures first and then i'm
going to put these guys off on the end
ok so i'm going to get this are you
happy with that you see the way i worked
out the reason why it done this is
because now you have a look at those two
numbers at the end they're actually not
two numbers like that itself is to know
me then this one is free right so this
is 10 x 10 x 10 touchdown time together
yeah and that's why you add these
indices some of you have actually
already noticed it you can just add
those two indices there they're two and
three and you get this number at 2.3 x
8.9 i don't expect anyone can do that in
their hair to solve an answer for me
yeah
oh yeah you go to the 2520 point okay
and so when you look at that you notice
a way I'm not done yet because that's
not between what is the first time back
to be between for scientific notation
one time between one and ten right so
there you have to unfortunately take the
working space for the next question and
say I'm going to change that 20.4 seven
into two point oh now this point you
have choice I could just move the
decimal place which would give me two
point zero four seven but I know I've
got a head here don't I right and 20 47
that's too many significant figures so I
could just go right at five now hold on
a second since i made this number from
here to here 10 times smaller how do i
compensate what changes yeah good so
this becomes a power of six right so you
want to think about it this way again
because i can multiply numbers in any
order I like there's a times 10 hiding
in there right that's 2.0 47 times 10 so
one of the tenants comes out and joins
it over here and there's my number okay
of course you can punch this into your
calculator as long as you can interpret
what you get after it well let's see I
mean I've given my I've got my all-time
be calculated I could when someone puts
the beer yeah affiky depending on the
mode that you're in well let's see
dewpoint whoa whiteout okay yes anyone
else having a good anyway ok ty sin
square
okay so if you are if you just punch it
in i mean this calculator which i assume
is in order is handing me i'll put it
off with a save another color it's handy
meatiest 20 47 is it two zeros on the
end I think it must be cheating no three
yeah 3 okay so yeah so you can see right
we've turned this question into now one
of these right like this is normal
rotation ordinary irritation and then
you've got to do the job to timber okay
now i'm going to rub off my work in
there so you can see my own site when
you have a look at this next one this
next one is a bit trickier because
there's division in there you can't just
divide numbers in any order you please
so let me just put this up here out of
the way so can someone give me a
suggestion not the answer but a way to
get toward the answer without reliable
to calculate it just yet any suggestions
yeah eliana
yep our 10 minus 3 minus 3 minus minus 3
minus hi yeah okay so hold on let me
just write that down first and then
we'll work out exactly where this
careful because this is perfect off on
this side here a little right well it's
perfect it's not finished yet okay i'm
over on the side here on mediterranean
unpack what's going on right it might
help sometimes in I don't have the
working in space over this i'm going to
do whatever here it might help you to
write this like string of numbers just
as a fraction we can do with fractions
to spend a long time with so maybe
she'll to ride along with me this i have
a pair of numbers and it looks like this
are you okay with that you see I just
replaced the division sign with a
fraction sir okay now what are we going
here again I'm going to take the other
suggestion you can see where the 4.1 on
one point three commas wrong it comes
from there ok so I'm going to leave
those scientific sorry those significant
i'm out front that's good now what
happens here you can think about this
just in terms of rules you might
remember i said to you when you've got
these are indices you can cross the line
and change the sign right so that's how
that five there on the bottom crosses
the line and you change the sign it
comes at minus five but the other way
you can think about it is this is all
abbreviation this is all short here what
is it short him for let's think I this
guy first right what is that shorthand
form when you've gotta like when we look
here right when you multiply by
something with the negative index
it's about division isn't it right like
a negative index means you divide by 10
that's how I read them so if you've got
a 3 there then you're dividing by 10 3
times right your once and it twice and
then at third time provide you don't rub
off your own writing in the process okay
so three divisions by 10 so i'm just
going to write that okay / 10 / 10 9 10
that's this guy right now I think about
this well he's on the denominator so
he's dividing to how many times 5 times
that's what the index meeting so i'm
going to write one more two more regal
normal fun we've done this cap they go
now of course this is very tiresome this
is why we have index notation because
it's a who wants to remove anything
anybody got time for that so therefore
we follow this all into how many
divisions are we doing we're doing minus
three minus five that's eight of them so
I've still haven't done with that guy at
the front but that's how I write this
division so much more concise so much
master okay and then I'm gonna use my
calculator someone already done this
done 4.1 / 1.3 any takers
sorry I think my case LOL 9.15 they go
um you had more decimal places than you
yeah yeah relevant good so you've got
more decimal places but it sounds like
they're going to round down so we just
want the three most senior need to
decide times taken any of it are you
happy with that and again if you
calculate it ought to tell you this if
it's already configured for scientific
notation you might get do you have
0.0000 you do ya say Leah check your
multipliers and what divides and what's
next to each other almost certainly
you've put two things together for it to
be so we'll check okay now um someone
got some answers for A&F let me give you
my answers for Lori wife is up okay I'm
right back baby